[Music]
behind glassy facades in financial
centers lie deals which determine the
flow of money but there are serious
questions about where some of it goes
and what some of it funds
a new investigation shared exclusively
with sky news shows that tens of
billions of pounds is financing work
like this
banks and asset managers investing
underwriting and loaning to agribusiness
linked to deforestation they tell us
they're green institutions but they just
keep doing it the research team analyzed
70 000 deals struck with 20 of the worst
offending businesses they say many banks
profited to the tune of tens of millions
of pounds they're very good at telling
us how green they are but what we found
is this gaping hole between what they
say in public and what they actually do
so when you follow the money and look at
their revenue streams look at their
actions you realize that they're not as
clean as they say they are
in fact since the paris climate
agreement in 2016 financial institutions
in europe the us and china have made
deals worth 120 billion pounds with
firms linked to tropical deforestation
u.s bank jp morgan was the biggest
lender making deals worth over seven
billion pounds while in the uk hsbc was
the biggest financer making deals worth
over five billion
hsbc alone made estimated proceeds of
nearly 30 million pounds from these
deals that's despite a pledge four years
ago to stop financing firms accused of
deforestation
in a statement it said hsbc has exited
is in the process of exiting or has no
banking relationship related to forestry
palm oil or cattle with the majority of
entities named in the report
it says it's ended relationships with
customers that don't comply with its
policies and is committed to tackling
deforestation jp morgan declined to
comment there's nothing illegal about
these deals but many banks have pledged
not to make them however there's a
growing argument that self-regulation
hasn't worked and what's needed is a
change in the law
the government's flagship environment
bill is due next week a perfect
opportunity according to some
neil parish tabled an amendment to ban
these type of financial deals but it was
rejected the legislation is always
important because you can then go to
these major banks major companies and
actually say you have acted illegally
you must stop and we can take direct
action but even despite all of that the
government rejected your amendment but
that doesn't stop us until thorgy to
government
and i think the government has come a
long way in the environment built
towards the direction we want
cutting down forest not only contributes
to climate change but is devastating to
local communities
cutting off the finance would
substantially cut down the practice
helen and smith sky news